[Music]  celebrities still furious that hundreds  of their private photos were leaked  online huge story well today I hate to  be the one to break it to you even more  photos were hacked and released now some  of the new celebrity photos are really  embarrassing they could ruin careers  let's take a look Kim Kardashian very  embarrassed about this leaked photo  where check it out  she's reading a book look at this this  is scandalous it's another hack photo  it's Prince trying on chinos at jcpenney  yeah look at this one  Guy Fieri quietly eating a healthy salad  this is scandalous it's an NBA player  kissing a woman who's actually his wife  yeah  next it's the cast of duck dynasty at a  gay pride parade that's problem here's a  hat photo of Vladimir Putin crying at  the movie frozen yeah here's a photo of  Liam Neeson calling 911 in his kitchen  and finally here's Justin Bieber waiting  in his gynecologists office that's just  [Applause]  you  [Applause]  you